because that's Monday June 4th because
you guys
[Applause]
you rank your head by one here now yeah
I'm the flash man and a bunch of other
movies ladies and gentleman the
world-famous Joey
I don't want those Applegate was in the
holiday
[Music]
what
Tuesday night we want to flap this come
ahead work back here we're here already
at the [__] Walsh on the flapper Sun
with our own [__] logo there
we're getting ready it's a cream of
coffee show routine
and [__] Kate filling us something
like that murder is going don't matter
unless see the devil tonight like we're
seeing that we might understand
this
this way cool
is that what it was that come on it that
it there soldier
members wheeling
we will you spit at that somebody came
in in my corner they spent like a man
instead my pocket
somebody came in the muffins and that's
it that's that we're like four days away
from shooting them same five days away
do I have any idea what I'm gonna say
not [__] really but that's the whole
thing going into the unknown not knowing
no big deal this is it a [__] parking
driveway people expect like 20 people
none of it this is during the week it's
seven nights a week it's uncle Joey on a
solo tip I'm gonna hang out with no
value put music on the car you know like
uh some [__] think of making moves in
my head only nobody
and I said that's that
we're here we'll quit you want to get
good at stand-up you gotta want every
[__] night two shows three shells are
like this is it
whether you doing comedy one year you
gonna calmly 27 years I'm fighting for
my life on [__] Monday like 28
minutes seems like nothing on fight for
my [__] life but I'm looking forward
to I'm like Julius Erving in 77 when the
aviate disband and he had like [__]
six out of ten leading in the categories
and I gotta go prove yourself in the NBA
and what do they do one all-star
something he went [__] - score 30
points got the MVP quota [__] listen
[__] you think you're dealing but you
want an inspirational I'll give you
inspiration and it comes in all colors
while they get the camera break
I can make a few states
keep selling our business
all together right from the top good
little kick block got the stick that's
all this should be it all weekend and
there's a shirt underneath me how good
is this [__] John wait for him this
is the top ship and the sweatiest
professor pyrrolidone [__] around 309
when I walked and got a to 81
[Applause]
wait watch appoints a [__] point you
you [__] keep you awake
before
no joke
is absolutely
you know
[__] have been on fire and chubby one
because it will people say
[Music]
come up to the stage my brother you guys
know with the pregnant shop
most big so corny fans again
I'm Duke team you lost we can double
check you know
the great
sentence you with 90 days camp and
county jail if he goes what about what
we say he goes he's he can be 90 days I
can do that standing up my head see you
get back on your [__] feet
before they just bumbling [__]